foreign
[Music]
foreign
world leaders have gathered for the
United Nations General Assembly in our
U.S correspondent Mark Stone joins us
live hello to you again mark across
events for us at the UN General Assembly
and of course Ukraine is front and
center
yes hi Sally I I don't think uh it is
any surprise that Vladimir Putin has
chosen tonight to head to address uh the
Russian Federation
um because he is using the moment to
seize the Limelight from the U.N he
knows that the rest of the world is
meeting here he's one of the few leaders
who has not turned up his foreign
minister Sergey lavrov is here on his
behalf but you're right Ukraine is
without question at front and center the
U.N General Assembly meets once a year
180 or so heads of state heads of
government as well and it is the key
Global diplomatic forum and it hasn't
met in person for three years because of
the uh the pandemic so the fact that
they've met in person now should be I
suppose business as usual but it very
much is not because the the geopolitical
landscape has changed fundamentally
since the last time they were here in
person changed because of Russia's
actions in Ukraine and War in Europe and
I think it weighs heavily on the minds
of the leaders here and I was very
struck uh when we we spoke to a couple
of leaders um or foreign ministers as
well over the course of of today I was
struck by their their somber tone but
also uh the the way with which they
dismissed these these sham referendums
have a have a listen first of all to
Ukraine's foreign minister I should say
that Ukrainian President Vladimir
zielinski is not here he's been given
special dispensation to to appear on on
video link but his foreign minister is
here and we caught up with him a little
earlier on
the referendums will change nothing it's
uh Russia is do is it's an act of
desperation for Russia but it is not
going to help them thank you thank you
now I also spoke to Joseph Burrell who's
the EU foreign policy Chief effectively
at the foreign minister you could say of
the European Union
um he I was really struck by what what
he said he repeated what uh what we
heard there from the uh from the foreign
minister of Ukraine and others as well
including Emmanuel macron that it's a
joke it's a sham it doesn't mean
anything but I also asked him how he
fixed this war will will end when it
will end
can you imagine a referendum in the
middle of a wall in a part of a
territory who has military occupied and
belongs to another country is there any
guarantee or whatever for this
referendum no we are not going to
recognize that how does this war come to
an end now
I don't know that's pretty worrying EU
foreign policy Chief doesn't know I mean
that's quite sobering nobody knows
everybody that has gone to the Kremlin
and discuss with Putin asking him to go
to the negotiation table let's come back
with a single answer no
no it will continue the war because they
have military objectives that they still
haven't got and as far as that I don't
have this military objective I will
continue fighting
the White House is also released words
today reflecting President Biden's View
at the White House incidentally
officials there had said weeks ago that
they believe Russia would try and carry
out these referenda that they appear now
to be setting in in place but the White
House officials have also said they
believe that Russia is going to announce
the Vladimir Putin or indeed his defense
minister is going to announce some sort
of immobilization of forces so so we're
a a turn in the Ukrainian conflict
certainly very worrying from the
perspective of Western diplomats here
Russia does appear to be extremely
isolated but it doesn't appear to be
affecting Vladimir Putin's state of mind
or his his objectives as he would see
them tomorrow will be a key day we're
going to hear tomorrow morning U.S time
from the American President Joe Biden
who flew from London up to Washington
and is flying up here tomorrow at that
address we understand will be focused
largely on Ukraine and and on what the
UN the United Nations body can do to try
and help bring this conflict to an end
so a key day tomorrow